You're comparing somebody saying fight like hell in the context
of a political campaign in the context of a democratic
>> Are you capable of listening to an alternative point
of view? Well, shut up then. Shut up and listen if you're capable
of it. Now, you can't compare somebody saying fight like hell
in the context of a political campaign with what I explained
earlier, which is when you call people >> campaign was
over. >> Shut up and listen to an alternative opinion.
Why is >> just stop stop arguing with me. Don't come on
this panel to argue with me. >> That you people have a
complete inability to listen to opinions that you don't like.
Why can't you just sit there and actually hear what I'm saying?
>> I'm waiting. >> You can't com Oh my god.
>> Okay, hold on. Let's see here. Here's we do panel joins
the discussion. We got We
>> Dave Ruben.
I'm sure we're all um >> Dave Ruben Chank the lady with
the star David and then Frankie Munz. Damn, >> what a lineup.
What a lineup. I have to I'll be right back. I'm just going to
grab some food real quick. Different views here on politics we've
all had over many years. I'm sure we're all joined by the same
view. This isn't
that the consequence of it could be very farreaching. Dave Rubin,
let me start with you. You know, this is a
deliberate, pre-planned execution
of a high-profile conservative
who,
irony of ironies, was the guy probably leading the charge to
sit down with people whose views you don't agree with. In other
words, almost the opposite of what this shooter uh appears to
believe that he represented. What is your reaction to it? Well,
peers, before we do the political side of this, I just lost a
friend. My friend was assassinated. A man who I spent an awful
lot of time with, who I broke bread with many times, who I sat
at weddings with. >> All right. All right. I'm back. I'm
back. I'm back.
Dave Rubin. It It's kind of weird. Okay.
This is very weird as creators do sometimes. All right. To go
and be like, "Hey, just so you guys all know, I was best friends
with that person who died. I was like best guys. My close close
close close friend. It's like [__] you guys met like
what five times.
I don't know. Maybe maybe him and uh maybe him and Charlie Kirk
met a lot more though. They both did like the like the what do
you call the political event circuit. So it's possible they met
a lot. >> Who I toured with and did many of these college
shows with. a man who uh as I was leaving the left about a decade
ago and realizing the hysteria of the progressives who welcomed
me even though we had various different opinions on very closely
held things like abortion and marriage and taxes and death penalty
and all of these things. And in the 10 years or so that I knew
Charlie Kirk, I never had one bad experience with him. I I had
only good experiences with him. Uh to your point about the political
part of this, yes, Charlie was better at reaching across the
aisle than anyone. I like to think that I'm pretty good at it,
but as an
>> apostate from the left, someone who left the left, uh
in some sense, they they want less to do with me than even someone
like him. So, it became harder for me to reach across the aisle.
Charlie spent his life trying to widen the tent that is the conservative
movement. He wanted the ex- liberals like me and Elon Musk and
Joe Rogan and Tulsi Gabbard and RFK, the thing that Donald Trump
represents in a wide tent MAGA movement because it's based in
America and freedom and I don't know anyone literally anyone
on earth who was doing it better than him. So I mourn deeply
deeply for my friend and I mourn for America because in your
intro you laid it out correctly. There's a lot of anger right
now. There's a lot of sadness. I can assure you of that. There's
a lot of anger and I feel it's incumbent on me and hopefully
guys like you, peers, uh, to be a little bit better right now
because otherwise this thing, this very precious experiment could
veer out of control uh, unbelievably quickly. >> I think
that's completely right. Um, you and I have talked a lot about
the toxic nature of political discourse in >> They don't
have like anybody who's on like really the political like establishment
left unless it's this guy. >> Kind of interesting. And
you've been very critical of the woke left actually in particular
and the way they've over demonized everyone calling everybody
fascist and so on. It seems that this 22-year-old shooter had,
you know, anti-fascist insignia on his ammunition. It's pretty
clear, I think, that he hated Charlie Kirk and wanted to silence
him. You know, we don't know his exact political allegiance.
that may or may not emerge in the next few hours and days. But
certainly he was behaving
like a fascist. You know, a fascist at their heart will stifle
disscent by murdering people. And this is exactly what this person
has done in the absurd. >> The British dude makes Oh yeah,
Constantine Kissen joins. I'm going to like that. Okay, I'm going
to enjoy >> Guys, of being anti-fascist.
>> Yeah. Um, so I think that this is a huge problem in
America right now. Uh, so to the point that Dave's making, um,
look, so Dave changed some of his opinions and and didn't change
others, right? I didn't change any of my opinions, but Charlie
and I had, uh, many conversations. He came on the Young Turks
at the Republican National Convention and the Democratic National
Convention. I went to America Fest. I got a lot of heat for going
to America Fest, but the part of that that that's left out is
that Charlie invited me to it. And not because I had changed
any of my opinions, but because I hadn't changed any of my opinions.
And then once we had those conversations, what we found out was
yes, we still deeply disagree on many things. If you know, uh,
state of race, >> I don't think Chanks changed a lot, but
Chank's like kind of naive and he thinks like Charlie had a good
faith reason to want him there, right? There's very um there's
very like it's not super obvious concept of like negative like
that you can do this thing where you make somebody who you think
would be useful to you receive a lot of hate
that pushes them towards you, right? You know that things are
very polarized. If I associate with you, I know people who hate
me are going to hate on you and if I play it just right, they
might push you towards me. I think Chenk's kind of been pushed
more in in terms of at least on a personal level to be aligned
with a lot of right-wingers because of that.
>> race relations, uh, power dynamics in America, I could
go on and on, right? But it turns out we actually did agree on
a bunch of things. Uh, housing, paid family leave, uh, how the
American people are, uh, being taken advantage of by the powerful,
corruption, all these things. So, you don't get to there unless
you have conversations.
So, >> Oh, the Discord overlay crashed. Hold on.
Wait, where did it What happened? >> Hello. One second.
Did I bring it back?
>> Hello. What's going on? Uh, they broke this site. They
like actually totally ripped their site completely. The people
who made made reactive Discord, they like totally destroyed it
for no reason.
I have no idea why they did it. Um, it's like totally broken
now. They totally [__] it for no reason.
>> It's like very baffling to me. I have no I have no idea
why they did this. They like totally destroyed it.
>> Where's my character?
>> It disappeared cuz the Discord overlay broke. They totally
ripped the website for some reason. >> I just wanted to
make you repeat everything that you just said. >> Oh, it's
just totally broken. So, the website's totally broken. Cool.
Yeah, the website's totally broken right now. Um, yeah, we'll
fix it. Hold on. There might be Do I have like the old version
of the Discord overlay? I don't think I >> We'll we'll
just go we'll roll like this for a little bit. >> I know
some on the right certainly were shutting down conversations
earlier in my lifetime. Still some >> Oh, yeah. I do. Whoops.
There we go. >> Thank you.
>> All right, I'll back it up a little bit. >> American
people are uh being taken advantage of by the powerful, corruption,
all these things. So, you don't get to there unless you have
conversations.
So I know some on the right certainly were shutting down conversations
earlier in my lifetime. Still some today are making that argument.
And in their anger today and then and justifiable anger uh there,
you know, there some were talking about striking back. And then
on our side, yes, there's way too much censoring, way too much
uh never talk to anyone else, just stick within your own tribe.
Well, how are we ever going to heal a country? Especially if
you're from the left, guys. We're supposed to be the side that
has empathy. I'm not saying the right doesn't. I'm just saying
that we historically have prided ourselves on having empathy
and reaching out and having conversations and healing and uniting.
So I the way that this country is going and both sides are going
is a deep deep problem. And one of the issues peers honestly
is media and algorithms. It rewards extreness and the more extreme
you are the more rewarded you are. And so we've got a way to
fix that. If we don't fix it,
the money and >> is Shank is Shank a fan of the stream?
Shank's just making some great points right now. And >> you're
totally monetarily incentivized to push the temperature as far
as you can, as fast as you can, and say the most extreme things
you can without getting banned. That's like where the name of
the game is right now in terms of politics. And it's a little
crazy. things might have to slow that down a little bit, guys.
>> And the spinning out of control of both sides political
fervor
is going to be an enormous problem for this country. We've got
to stop right now. Look, >> either we could use this moment
to hate each other more >> or we could use this moment
as an inflection point to begin to heal and to unite and realize
that we're all Americans together. There's nothing wrong with
disagreeing and we could say that fervently without crossing
the line into hating each other, thinking that both sides are
not of some sort. And you're right, peers, even I've gotten called
in by some portions of the left for disagreeing on trans issues
5%. No, that's too much, guys. It isn't >> Oh, hey, the
overlay came back. Cool. >> About me. It's about the hatred
that gets built in and entrenched when we can't even talk to
the other side. Yeah. >> And we can't see each other as
fellow
>> Batty, I want to play a clip. This is of Charlie Kirk
on Piers Morgan Unensored in November 2023. At the time, uh we
just had the start of the is war. I'd been defending Israel's
right to defend itself at that stage. I've obviously become a
lot more critical uh in in this year certainly, but at the time
he talked very pertinently about actually the left and in particular
in relation to uh campus colleges. Let's take a
>> The very same people who've been behaving in this way
uh effectively supporting a terror group uh have gone out of
their way to deplatform and shame and cancel anyone who on maybe
on the right it has to be so on the conservative side who've
deviated from their world view. So free speech to them seems
a very complex issue.
You know that >> ah this is going to be so funny. He's
going to have to talk about how much he loves free speech right
now, isn't he? >> That's right. And look, I mean, you we
have to be disciplined in how we advocate for d, you know, dialogue
and free speech. And when I go to these college campuses, it's
come very clear, and you see this now manifesting in some of
the larger censorship regime that is taking over the West, that
if a young student finds disagreement
with a conservative or somebody on the right, they don't just
find the ideas objectionable. Some, in fact, a majority by a
recent Pew poll want to use force to try to silence and stifle
and even censor those differing ideas. >> I mean, how precient
Batty of those comments seem now because that's exactly
>> what a great principle. Okay. Or sorry, what a great
illustration of people who don't stand behind a principle. Okay,
that's what I should say.
Man, people really don't like what some of these people who don't
love Charlie Kirk have to say. I guess they'll just do anything
like try to get them fired to make them stop talking. >> What
has happened here? Um, what's your reaction to Charlie's >> Is
Vinnie on his phone? Vinnie is on his phone. I also don't know
when Vinnie got here, but Vinnie Oshana, ladies and gentlemen,
well-known
recovering heroin addict. Okay, Vinnie Oana,
>> let's go. >> Murder. And how do you feel about
the way things may go from here? >> Um, thank you so much
for having me, Pierce. It's obviously still very raw for a lot
of us. Um,
I'm finding myself very caught between on the one hand wanting
to honor his legacy of um, unity through debate.
>> Not that there's anything wrong with being a recovering
addict. Um, yeah. No, there's nothing wrong with it. >> And
coming together to take down the temperature and then wanting
to honor his legacy of telling the truth.
And the truth is this is not a both sides issue.
The killer him according to police reports
because he found Charlie Kirk to be spreading hate.
This is a view shared by every single prominent Democrat. Yes.
>> Believe that's misinformation. I believe they said the
family member, not him, the family member said Charlie Kirk was
spreading hate. So why be accurate? Why actually read something?
Why actually do any research? Why look into anything? Jesus Christ.
>> People on blue sky advocating for violence.
But what actually caused this was the utterly quotidian
utterly ubiquitous demonization
>> of the political
>> quotidius. I don't know what that means. But what actually
caused this was the utterly quotidian
>> quotidian
tittian
>> of or occurring every day daily.
>> She couldn't just say daily. I hate I hate people.
Um, by the way, that guy is almost certainly like a lefty. The
guy the shooter, just so you all know. But this person doesn't
know any of the facts and so they're claiming it from a place.
I just don't like it. But what actually caused this was the utterly
quotidian,
utterly ubiquitous demonization
of the political opposition from the left
and it has just led to violence because they said the other side
were >> dude
I guess these guys all had their programming overridden. Okay,
they don't remember how they won the election by just going those
people are they support they're part of a ring. Do you guys understand
how like conservatives won the last election? That's that's how
you won it. And I get that the on are on your side now, so you've
kind of lost the program and you've forgotten it. But yes, you
were you were complaining that they were covering up a ring that
they were all that they're trying to trans your kids so they
can [__] them, right? Jesus Christ. That's pretty
bad, man. That's I dare I say worse than fascist. >> They
said that speech is violence.
To combine those two things together is to sign the death warrant
of prominent conservatives. And that is what we are seeing again
and again and again. And it is utterly facitious to suggest that
there is any comparison
between political violence on both sides. Every example they
bring is not actually showing that. Whether it's Governor Shapiro
whose attempted assassination was from a free Palestine leftist
or whether it was the Minnesota
assassinations which were >> the Minnesota one is particularly
egregious. I don't we'd have to look into Josh Shapiro to see
exactly what happened there. But the Minnesota one trying to
trying to paint that as like a Democrat operative that just seems
crazy >> from somebody who said he was operating at the
behest of Democrat Governor Tim Walls. There is a culture among
Democrats at the highest level to suggest that their political
opposition are a danger and that suggests that their lives are
forfeit. And I want to come together. I do. I love what Shank
said. It brought tears to my eyes. I had to reach for a tissue
while you were playing Charlie's words. But at the same time,
we cannot unite with people who are lying to our faces about
who we are. who will not take responsibility for the fact that
they suggested that we are
because of totally legitimate views that reflect the majority
of Americans. So what I say is let the left >> I don't
know if that's true. Dude,
Charlie Kirk did not have views that reflect the majority of
Americans.
>> I don't know why that gets >> We were wrong. It
is legitimate to vote for Donald Trump. It is legitimate to be
pro-life.
It is legitimate
post what what's that
>> that Charlie Kirk was extraordinary but that he had
very common views for Americans or something like that. >> I
mean maybe they're starting to become more more uh more
normalized.
Did you see someone said Kirk is racist for saying armor defect
to a Chinese audience member, but he actually just said chank
because he was debating Chank. Nope. Didn't see that. That sounds
stupid >> to believe that there are only two genders and
we >> Yeah, Rob. Rob doesn't have a good handle on what
like is the standard in America either. But >> you were
wrong to suggest that that was not the case. We were wrong to
say that that is hateful. When they say that, I am waiting with
open arms to take down the temperature.
>> Lewis Goodall, you are on the left. Um, and the one
thing that's really struck me about this, you know, I don't dispute
for a moment that there are people on the far right that commit
a lot of acts of violence and would can be equally hateful. Uh,
that's my personal view. Uh but
I have been truly shocked, genuinely truly shocked by the sheer
enormousity
of brazen
dehumanized calls on social media from people on the woke left,
the sort of far-left,
uh which has been calling themselves progressive, but in my view
are the opposite. But how they've reacted to Charlie Kirk's death.
We've got a little mashup of some of it.
Oh, let's go. >> Ding dong, the witch is dead.
>> We think that
>> I've been truly disturbed by what these 20 to 30year-old
white women are saying on Twitter. Okay, >> these people.
>> This is horrifying, guys. >> Dingdong, the witch
is dead.
>> We think that Charlie Kirk just got shot in the neck.
Hey. Ooh. Ah.
>> I would say pour one out for Kirky boy, but I don't
waste good beer on little >> Charlie Kirk just got put
down like a dog in Utah and I could not be happier. >> I
will not. >> So did your hair stylist. What the was that
[__] on their head? >> Just got put down. >> That
mop. I don't know. Looks like a wig. Actually, I'd fully believe
that's a wig. >> Like a dog in Utah. And I could not be
happier. I will not ever ever ever ever ever feel bad when bad
people get what the [__] they deserve. >> Dude,
anybody who does like cuts like this in their in their shorts
or any segments, these people. Okay, we need we need whatever
whatever happened. Okay, there was a person who is as dedicated
to getting rid of Charlie Kirk as I feel people should be dedicated
to getting rid of people who do Tik Toks like this. Okay, I
Dude, this is the jump cuts like the weird jump cuts with the
different angles on your face. You're like trying to like mew
into the camera. I >> ever ever ever ever ever feel bad
when >> your game pig.
>> Reban Ruben donated $5. Can you do a quick react to
a vid I posted in stream chat if you have time? >> If I
have time, absolutely. Thank you for the five, Ruben. Ruben,
>> the deserve. >> [__] stoked right
now. You want to know why I'm so stoked? >> [__]
Yes.
got AK and he's gone. He did say that gun deaths were an acceptable
side effect of gun rights.
>> There there are hundreds.
>> That sucks. Yeah, I'm totally just about those people.
Those people aren't serious. Those people suck. Anyway, moving
on. Can we discuss how Elon Musk is talking about how you should
you are like going to be overrunning your country? You have to
fight back now. And can we discuss how that's probably getting
like 100x the views of anything those people? Sorry, like 10,000x
the views of anything. He said prominent, right? He did say prominent.
Yes.
Thousands maybe more examples like this. But we've seen teachers.
We've seen uh hospital executives. We've seen people who want
to run places like, you know, the Oxford University. We've got
a little mashup of some of it. normity of brazen
dehumanized calls on social media from people on the woke left,
the sort of far-left
uh which has been calling themselves progressive, but in my view
are the opposite, but how they've reacted to Charlie Kirk's death.
We've got a little mashup of some of it. >> Okay, so he
didn't say prominent. He did not say prominent >> and I
uh >> he just ran, you know, a couple Tik Toks in a row.
That's it. two young children. I find it utterly despicable but
also quite terrifying actually that they're so brazenly doing
this. What is your >> Everybody's saying more like regressive
left. Let let Constantine come in. He's that's his line. Okay,
that's what he's going to say. They're more like the regressive
left is what I like to call them. Yeah, let Constantine kiss
and join. Don't take his lines from him. >> Reaction to
that? Well, my reaction is that I think it's reprehensible and
I think it is part of a much wider pattern of behavior driven
by partly social media, but in particular the hyperpolarization
of American politics, which is part of a big trend of legitimizing
violence, of making violence an acceptable means of prosecuting
your politics. where I would disagree possibly with you, possibly
with other members of the panel is that this is somehow just
confined to the left or the idea that this is just happening
on the left. Yes, there have been examples of that. We've just
seen it just now. I was disgusted at the reaction to what happened
with Luigi Manzion earlier in the year. Very similar sort of
phenomenon. But let's see where it's happened in other parts
of the right. Do you remember what happened with Paul Pelosi,
for example, Nancy Pelosy's husband almost killed to death? What
was the reaction of not just some random leftwing accounts, not
some teacher, not whatever, but Don Jr., Donald Trump Jr., he
decided to put out a picture of a hammer and some underpants
and say, "I've got my Paul Pelosi Halloween costume tonight."
This is the wider legitimization of violence that we're seeing.
And let's just have a look. I mean, you know, let's talk about
>> Guys, don't make fun of the Bonger misspeaking, okay?
He's like he's one v he's 1 v10 right now, okay? They're going
to keep bringing people in to fight with him. accounts that I've
been looking at. You've been horrifying. What I've seen on Twitter,
some stuff I've seen on Blue Sky, some stuff I've seen on X over
the course of the last 24 hours. Liberals can never be allowed
to run this country again. How can you coexist with people that
want to murder you if you vote Democrat at this point? You're
a demonic evil person. I will support whatever saves our country.
Trump has a blank check as far as I'm concerned. I could go on.
I could go on and I could go on and I could give a list of all
of the many occasions we've seen in recent years of right-wing
hardright far-right terrorism that we saw against what happened
in Minnesota. I mentioned Paul Pelosi, Josh Shapiro. In fact,
I disagree with just as a matter of of fact investigators found
in the Shapiro case. Online activity and writings included extreme
right-wing anti-semitic conspiracy theories and rhetoric against
Shapiro, who is of course a Democrat and in Michigan. And even
in the last 24 hours or so, what do we see from Laura Luma on
Illinois, the Democratic Congresswoman?
>> This guy's rolling with the Medi Hassan worksheet. Okay,
>> Laura Luma being a very senior mag. At the end of the
day, everyone needs to realize that Ilan Omar is a bloodthirsty
Muslim terrorist sympathizer who has no place in our country.
Her presence in Congress is a national security threat and she's
an enemy from within. So please, the idea that there is some
sort of asymmetry on this, the fact of the matter is America
and indeed the UK as well, we've got into a really negative cycle
here where basically the temperature goes up and it goes up and
it goes up and then sometimes some of the people who are responsible
for that turn around and go, "God, I can't believe it's so hot
in here. Everyone needs to pull back from the brink. Social media
needs to actually be reformed and needs to be. >> See,
this guy is uh I don't know if he got sent an email for like
the wrong, but he's he's like in the wrong place. He's making
like actual points, tangible points, okay?
He's like saying what's true, but that's not going to matter.
They're all looking at him like, dude, they're all so confused.
Look at their faces. None of them are happy that this guy's making
good points. None of them are happy that he's making like actual
arguments. They're like, wait, don't you don't you know where
we are, bro? Don't you know this is where we all scream like
this is all where we all just like fight for no why are you making
a reasonable point. Can you shut the up? Can you shut the [__]
up? They're all so confused right now. >> Elon Musk has
been pretty responsible for some of this stuff that we've seen
as well. So let's not pretend. If we pretend that this is just
a problem of the left or of liberalism or of wokeism or whatever
you want to say, this problem is not going to be any better or
get any better. Let's use this as a moment for all of us to look
within ourselves and decide to be better. >> Okay. We've
been joined on the panel by PBD podcast angry patriot Vincent
Oshan. Vinnie, great to have you back on our sense and I'm sorry
it's in such awful circumstances that we're talking uh on this
Friday, but your response to what Lewis Goodall's just said that
this is a problem on all sides that political violence has been
ratcheting up and that there's a collective issue that needs
to be dealt with. Well, Pierce, thank you for having me and hello
to everybody on the on the panel. Pierce, I'm I'm sorry, but
trying to compare a photo of a Pelosi hammer for a Halloween
thing to somebody getting shot in the neck in front of his family
at a campus is
>> He didn't compare those Vinnie. Vinnie starts off with
not being able to follow the conversation. Vinnie starts off
with not being able to understand what's being said. Classic
Vinnie just coming in here and just being like, I like what you
just said right there. and I'm going to make up what it was.
I I didn't really listen to you, but I'm going to kind of make
up whatever he just said and I'm going to do my best. >> The
fact that you're trying to make the two comparison is absurd.
Okay? And if we want to since you're on the left and you you
you have those beliefs, give me something that the left is positive
about. Cuz from what we're seeing, they're the they're pro-abortion.
They're pro- celebrating assassination. They're pro- open border.
Give me give me something positive that the left is running on
because at the end of the day, they're at the third. They're
pro-abortion.
Pro- assassination.
Yeah. All things in balance, guys. Okay. Wait, not all things
in balance. Yeah. All things in balance. Pro immigration. Okay.
Bring new people in. Babies.
Political analysts. I guess political influencers. I don't know.
I don't know. Democrats 35 year low approval rating. And And
peers, I have to go a little bit deeper. I have to go. This isn't
about left. This isn't about right. Charlie was a proponent.
He was a Christian praising Jesus Christ everywhere that he went.
And I think that's where we are, Piers. Ephesians 6:12 says,
"For we not wrestle with flesh and blood, Piers. It's principalities.
It's evil. It's dark forces in high places." And I I'm
It drives me crazy, Piers, that we've gotten to this point. And
I when Tim Walls and these people are like, "Well, I want I I
would love to be on this because I feel like I could have like
the tangible discussion, but I could also just start going like,
Vinnie,
don't you feel like it's just obviously Israel that Charlie Kirk?"
Because they need to get the heat off of Epstein. Like, where
are the Epstein files, Vinnie? Seems like this is all a distraction.
They literally Charlie to distract from the Epstein files, Vinnie.
Vinnie. Vinnie, why aren't you mad about >> Woke up. I
wanted to hear bad news. Hearing TMZ lying when their freaking
people are back there cheering. cheering of a murder of a guy
that did what, peers. He went to college campuses. He was peaceful.
He just wanted to have a a a debate, a conversation. And it is
the left. Okay. When Joe Biden got diagnosed with uh colon cancer,
who was celebrating, who what how many thousands of people were
out there praying and hoping for this guy to to recover? Okay.
No, there's something that's captured here. That image. >> I
promise you I could go find a bunch of random Tik Toks of people
saying, "Oh, awesome. from Joe Biden sign that guy >> that
montage that you played. Did you see the eyes of these people?
They are captured by something dark and they don't even know
it. Piers, that's where we are. And I want to say something,
Pierce, before I give it back. Charlie was not murdered. He was
murdered. And I want to say this in the Bible, and I'm sorry.
I never was this guy. Oh, that's going to be a line that catches
on.
Never let them forget, guys. He wasn't murdered. He was martyed.
He wasn't murdered. He was martyed. He was not
He was martyed. I I dude I'm going to hear that so many times.
I >> appears but we're at the tipping point. We are here.
We have to understand that it's it's God or you're on the opposite
side. And chap Revelations 6:9 basically says when a martyr's
blood hits the throne of heaven, it turns the vengeance of the
king towards the evil ones on earth. So for all the people that
want to get mad and do something, stay calm and be easy because
God at the end of the day, peers, has vengeance on all these
people that are spilling innocent >> Are you really saying
that the American right, the Trump right, MAGA, has not got a
problem with political violence?
>> Are you comparing Wait, are you comparing us who by
the way?
How many years? That's 10 years. Hold on, hold on, hold on. Are
you comparing the two? Hold on. I'm not saying that the right
doesn't >> The guy's like trying to let him finish. Vinnie's
just like, "Hold on, let me finish." Are you comparing to Hold
on, hold on, hold on. Are you comparing to Hold on, hold on,
hold on. Get violence, but dude, I understand why this guy thinks
demons are possessing people. He's got a lot of voices in the
room with him right now. Okay, he's not talking to anybody who's
on the panel. He's literally just talking to the people who are
in the room with him right now. >> Tell me where they're
celebrating the murder of a father on a campus. Give me Give
it to me. Who celebrate Luigi Manion where he's in magazines
and girls want want to marry him and want to be with him? No,
you just have you just have No, you just have the president of
the United States son. You just have the president of the United
States son tweeting out a picture of a hammer making fun of a
guy who nearly got because of a right-wing maniac. Please do
not tell me that somehow that somehow one side is more morally
superior than the other. This is not and just while we're talking
about just excuse me while we're talking about political assassination.
What about January the 6th? What about January the 6th where
a MAGA decided to try to use violence to overthrow democracy
definition?
How many people excuse me since you're such an American historian?
How many people died on January 6,
a fellow United States Air Force? Excuse me. Excuse me. >> Six.
Actually, >> let me finish. A United States Air Force veteran
got shot subsequently in her freaking neck. Why? Hold on. Why?
Because she was unarmed. >> Wait. Wait. Was that somebody
on camera? >> Hold on. >> No one cut him off.
>> I'm telling you, there's there's a bunch of people there's
like voices in his head that are like talking. He's like yelling
at the voices.
>> Fellow United States Air Force Excuse me. Excuse me.
Let me finish. A United States Air Force veteran got shot. >> Dude,
dude, do you see the face the British guy makes? >> Excuse
me. Excuse me. Let me finish. A United States
>> Hold on. Can I go Can I go back a few >> What?
That >> you make that face at me. >> Yeah, probably.
>> What was that face? >> Air Force means you're
making a fantastic point right now. I should shut the up. >> Got
to let this person cook. No, it doesn't. I don't know what it
means when I make the face. Okay. I just have a sense of what
he means. >> Veteran God shut
in her freaking neck. Why? Hold on. Why? Because she was unarmed
and she was advancing to a hall. Please, please. I'm 100% with
you. I don't condone any violence, but the comparison is not
even close to what the left does. So, let's have some statistics
from your own promote it. >> Let's have some statistics
from your own government. These are your own government.
Now, I know you might not want to listen to the facts, but this
is the facts. A study from the US government itself says that
the majority of political violence in the United States occurs
from the right, not the left, from the right. We have also seen
in my own country
the assassination of a Labour MP Joe Cox. We saw what happened
in Norway with Anders Bearing Bravic. All violence on the right.
I >> this guy just Wait, did this guy just pull up? Why
would you pull up Anders
This guy not realize Andrew Breivik is like a a huge thing in
Europe. Okay. For Americans, that's like a Tuesday. Why did you
bring up These guys don't give a [__] about Andrew
Breik. I do not say as you seem to say sir that there one side
or other is morally superior to the other. I do not say that
there will not be political violence on one side or the other.
What seems and I find curious is your belief your fervor that
somehow one side of this debate is uniquely morally repugnant
and one is superior. The statistics are wrong. That's not right.
Doesn't support what you're saying. And the fact after fact after
fact and occasion after occasion after occasion shows the same
thing. And like I say, January the 6th itself was literally the
legitimization from your side of political violence at the highest
of levels. And what did Donald Trump do when he got back into
office? He pardoned the war sending a message that were there.
Were you excuse me, are you are you in the United States? Are
you in >> I just returned from the United States as I don't
need to be. >> Oh no. Vinnie Vinnie's One Direction. He
had to go. Are you in the United States right now? Yeah, I just
got back to the United States. Well, well, >> excuse me.
Are you >> That's not going to put Vinnie off. Vinnie's
got another direction to go in. I can feel it. I can feel it.
>> Are you in the United States? Are you an >> I
just returned from the United States. But I don't need to be
in the United >> Okay. So, wait. Are you Are you an American
citizen? >> Are you an American citiz? Are you an American
citizen? >> No. I want to ask you a question cuz you're
looking down reading stats and facts and I don't know where the
hell your sources are from. >> Wait, what? >> He
said, "I don't know what that's got to do with the price of fish."
>> Yeah. Idiot. >> What's wrong with British people?
>> I don't know why he says fish. It's
What's that got to do with the price of eggs? Price of a loaf.
>> Are you in the United States? >> Price of a loaf
is how you say it usually, right? >> Are you in America?
>> I just returned from the United States, but I don't
need to be in the United States for you. Are you an American
citizen? Are you American citiz?
>> No. I want to ask you a question cuz you're looking
down reading stats and facts and I don't know where the hell
your sources are from, but guess what? As an American, from seeing
what they did, excuse me, I let you talk. Please let me talk.
Okay. From what you mean to tell me what the left, your darling
left has done to the Republican party and Donald Trump alone
for 10 years, the calling for violence, the like Batia said,
all the negative rhetoric, hold on to the impeachments to shooting
him in the head and him saying, "I want peaceful protesting.
I want peaceful protesting." And then the FBI informants, all
the uh confidential human resources inside the freaking car on
January 6. That that's a whole
>> dude. Vinnie is Vinnie is uh you know oxygen not getting
to his brain right now going entirely to his face to turn his
face red >> argument debate that you don't want to get
into but as an American who lives in America and as a veteran
we see what's happening. I don't care about your Chad >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I do think it's funny. Well, I know
RFK called them that. But it's like I think we should arrest
everybody who's ever called Donald Trump. We've got to start
with JD Vance, right? We got to get it's got to be JD Vance first.
>> BT stats. The left
party that is inciting the violence and causing the >> Okay.
I want to bring in another guest now who will then join the panel
for the rest of the show. Constantine Kissing, author and host
of Trigonometry. Constantine, I've seen from your post that you've
been very personally
>> Oh god. >> By the death of Charlie Kirk. Where
does this horrific murder leave us in relation to political discourse
and the safety of public figures as a
This is uh when the Starbucks barista hands me the uh the card
reader and it he's watching for what my tip's going to be. Okay.
Come on, man. Come on, man. Come on, man. You know, Pierce, I
don't know if I I've been personally affected, but I know that
I've received messages from hundreds of people at this point,
ordinary people. Many of them nothing to do with politics. Uh
never paid attention to politics. Never really
>> what is what
>> here's just set him up like I know you've been personally
affected or you've said that you were personally affected and
he's just like, well, I don't know if I've been personally affected,
but I've seen people. What the
>> I don't know. I don't know what Pier's talking about.
Piers just cooks sometimes. Piers knows that all of these people
are talking about their personal memories with um with Charlie
Kirk.
>> which by the way, I I messaged Twitter. I was like,
"Hey, have you taken advantage? Have you monetized this yet?"
I talked to Charlie Kirk nine months ago. She should be She should
be absolutely like hammering that, right? >> Yeah, she
talked to Charlie Kirk on
>> Where? Oh, right. Right. >> I think I've got that
somewhere. Hold >> No, she can't. What she needs to do
is find Jesus.
>> And then she can monetize off of it. >> Charlie
Kirk came to me in a dream.
>> yeah. You can't remain an OF [__] and be
like and monetize off of this. >> She She needs to say
Okay. It needs to >> No, no, no. She needs to run with
this. >> By the way, >> she needs to Yeah, but she
needs to say after this panel, I shut my Only Fans down and I
started like actually politically streaming. Okay. Charlie, Charlie
set me on the right path. And I know he's looking over me today.
He's watching over me today, dude. And
>> the perverts on the internet are gonna lose their mind
trying to find her old oaf that doesn't exist. >> People,
many of them nothing to do with politics,
uh, never paid attention to politics, never really cared, who
were horrified and shocked by this in a very profound way. And
I think it's a number of things. You know, you've just had this
very fierce discussion about political violence and we're talking
about politicians, but people forget that Charlie was not a politician.
This is a 31-year-old guy who went around college campuses and
now his two young children. I mean, I I was putting my son to
bed last night and this is all so stu like I and it it shouldn't
matter, by the It shouldn't matter if he's a politician or not,
but like it's so annoying when people do this and it's like,
"No, you're wrong. He was an incredibly influential political
purp.
He was not a nobody. Stop pretending he's a nobody." Because
one, it shouldn't matter. I shouldn't have to stop you on this
and tell you to stop lying, but it makes me look like that makes
a difference. Or it makes me look like I'm arguing it makes a
difference. It doesn't, right? But when they lie, I'm just like,
"Dude, stop lying. Stop minimizing what this guy was politically.
He wasn't just a influencer. He wasn't just going to have a talk
on a college campus. That's not what he did." And I was thinking
of his
>> And and I know that millions of people around the world
are thinking about that because they didn't see Charlie as a
politician
because I guess with America's history of political violence
all the way back to Abraham Lincoln, uh we kind of know that
these things can happen. But I think what this has done is it's
taken violence into a whole new realm. It's taken violence into
the realm of people who just have conversations for God's sake.
And I think this changes everything in a very profound way. Of
course, it has the potential
to chill the debate, to scare people away from saying the things
that they believe, they think, the things that they think are
important to say. Um, I hope that doesn't happen. And I know
that my experience and the experience of many other people who
do speak in public over the last few days has been a shock and
horror and perhaps fear too that has morphed into resolve and
and and a and an unwillingness to let this become the way that
our conversations become silent, which I think is what Charlie
would have wanted. Um, but as for the debate we've just heard,
look, I I I am I'm in a very consily mood and I think it's important
that we're all responsible with our words, but I found it difficult
to sit there and listen to to this preposterous conversation
you've just had. Uh, I I don't understand what I mean, I this
>> what's preposterous about the >> Last year, I
sat across from one of your guests, Jen, on that particular occasion
in which he tried to persuade me for 20 minutes that Donald Trump
was a fascist.
That's what that's what that's how the left talks about their
political opponents. And I'm someone who's not politically affiliated.
I'm just looking at the facts of what I see. We have had for
the last 10 years the word what has happened to the word >> as
a result of the word the woke left's behavior is completely unacceptable.
This is a word that we had for a very specific group of people
that was supposed to describe people who believe in national
socialism and fascism.
That's these words have very specific meanings and the meanings
that they had were very important for being able to describe
people who are actually of that opinion and instead as long as
he's willing to disassociate from anybody who called Democrats,
he can be consistent and this could be a fine point. Okay, that's
all he's got to do. Anybody who implied that they're or anything
like that, it's uh he's got to distance from all of them, right?
He's got to totally totally go move on from all of them because
apparently that is what's getting people killed is that kind
of hyperbolic language guys has a really specific meaning. How
do you know that Camala Harris or Joe Biden are how do you know
that? Come on man. Both in America and here across the Atlantic
and Britain. We've had and we're not talking about people on
Twitter or people on blue sky. I'm talking about David Lambi
who's the current deputy prime minister talking about a group
of conservative euroskeptics and saying they're worse than we've
had this for decade for a whole decade now the complete dehumanization
of people for simply having political disagreements. And so when
I see that the killer of Charlie Kirk had these anti- so-called
anti-fascist inscriptions on his on his ammunition I'm not surprised.
I'm not shocked. Of course, this would happen. And and people
like to pretend that this has no consequence. Well, think about
it, Pierce. You're a man. I'm a man. If you and I thought that
fascism was actually here, as we keep being told, wouldn't it
be our duty to stand up and fight? So, can we really be surprised
then when some deranged guy picks up a rifle and shoots someone
who
I just want to know? This was the entire argument that people
did with the pizza gate. This is the exact pizza gate argument.
Now, nobody died there, but this is like exactly the pizza gate
argument that Dems used. And everybody was like, "That's crazy.
You have to be able to speak. It is It's all about free speech,
guys." It's like the exact same argument, right? If you say that
there's a ring of and you say they're like kidnapping kids, yeah,
it's people are going to have to stand up and fight. You have
to end it. It's like it's a it's your moral requirement to do
this, right? But it's like,
dude, I But like I think you should be able to speak and you
should be able to use hyperbole.
people on the media, people on TV saying is a fascist keep saying
is a Nazi is completely irresponsible. And I'll just make one
other point on this because you know we've had this conversation
and Lewis has talked about well there's violence on the left
and violence on the right. He's right. Of course there are deranged
people on both sides. In a country with easy access to firearms,
there will be that sort of violence like we've had seen in our
country. It's not just Joe Cox who's been killed in this country.
We also had Sir David Ames, an MP be in Britain, too. Uh, and
he was a member of the Conservative Party by an Islamist. And
on and on we go. But there's one thing that I've noticed, a great
mentor of one of mine once told me, he said, Constantine, the
greatest insights come from looking at what is not there. And
the one thing I have noticed that hasn't been there in my mind,
you tell me if this is different for you, Pierce, over the last
few days, I've had no expectation
that there would be burning, looting, riots in the streets, attacks
on police officers across America or Britain or the rest of the
West. We haven't seen any of that and we haven't expected any
of that. And that's because political violence has been normalized
on these far extremes of the left. And when you see those people
celebrating, what they are expressing is now a widely held opinion,
particularly among young people on the woke left, that if they
don't agree with somebody, if they're not getting their way politically,
they're entitled to use violence to achieve their aims. We took
cancel culture away from them when Elon Musk took over X and
opened up the conversation and forced other social media platforms.
>> Man, I feel like we could go into explaining why it's
not the same. I don't know if I want to,
right? It's definitely not the same. But also, let's not forget
Asmin Gold's got a digital riot going on right now where they're
like trying to get people fired from everything, right? Like
like people are behaving horribly.
Uh lives are being ruined. They're doxing and trying to get people
fired all over the internet right now. I don't know about you,
I've got this little conservative like libertarian kind of belief
that the way you make your money, the way you feed your family
is something that is sacred and shouldn't be attacked, right?
That it's kind of akin to your life. It's not quite the same
thing, but it is kind of akin. It's like close, right? Trying
to go after people's money and their ability to provide for their
families is insane. Like it's a it's
it's a massive overstep for somebody going wamp wamp at Charlie
Kirk dying. Wamp wamp.
That's wild to open up the conversation. So now instead of using
cancel culture, we've got violence culture and everybody has
to pull back. And I'm not calling for any kind of censorship
because censorship will not solve this. But the people who have
spent the last decade calling their political opponents fascist
and so on, they have blood on their hands and they need to look
in the mirror now and stop.
>> Yeah. I mean, Dave Rubin, I I've been on this theme
for a long time on this
>> burning, looting, riots in the streets, attacks on police
officers across America or Britain or the rest of the West. We
haven't seen any of that and we haven't expected any of that.
And that's because political violence has been
>> Elon Musk took over X and opened up the conversation
and forced other social media platforms to open up the conversation.
So now instead of using cancel culture, we've got violence culture
and everybody has to pull back. And I'm not >> I didn't
realize just how stupid that was. Now instead of cancel culture,
we have violence culture. Well, actually, you've got cancel culture.
The rightwing's got cancel culture. We're witnessing it in real
time.
We're literally witnessing it in real time for the exact same
[__] Like the exact same thing is happening. I really
don't like the jokes you make. The jokes you make are really
offensive. I'm going to get you fired.
Calling for any kind of censorship because censorship will not
solve this. But the people who have spent the last decade calling
their political opponents fascist
and so on, they have blood on their hands and they need to look
in the mirror now and stop.
>> Yeah. I mean, Dave Rubin, I I've been on this theme
for a long time on this show, and I've got a book called, ironically,
woke is dead coming out next month. And one of the themes of
the book is how radicalized so many on the woke left have become.
And I don't for a moment dispute there are people radicalized
on the right. But as somebody who used to identify quite happily
as a liberal, I found myself completely disassociated
from the woke left in a way I just never thought possible where
people on supposedly my side would start to become science deniers,
biology deniers, um but also develop this incredibly hateful
mindset that if if you didn't go along with everything that they
believed, you would be cancelled, you'd be destroyed, you'd be
shamed, you'd be vilified. And and now, as we've seen with Charlie
Kirk, you will actually be murdered in cold blood simply for
having opinions that they don't like. It is it is, as I said
at the start of this, it's unnerving. It It's quite scary, actually.
And when you see those Tik Tok videos of them so proudly talking
about this, joyously celebrating a murder like that, I I really
do fear about what is going on. >> Well, Piers, it's not
even that it's about his actual opinions. It's about the opinions
that many thought leaders on the left purport that he has which
are complete lies. So look, I am in somewhat of a reconciliatory
mode here. So I'd like to ask Jenk. I have 10 headlines here.
He has put up
>> Is that me? Is that you guys? >> Charlie Kirk.
They are on to ask Jenk. I have 10 headlines here. He has put
up about Charlie Kirk. They are on his channel right now. And
let's see. >> Uhoh. Jank, what have you been saying about
Charlie Kirk? Jank. >> If Jenk believes that these are
true, Charlie Kirk says prominent black women took white people's
spots. Charlie Kirk boasts about his all-white basketball team.
Charlie
Wait, is it Chank? I thought it was really irresponsible the
way you quoted Charlie Kirk. Chank, I thought it was really irresponsible
when you said what Charlie Kirk said directly. Chank, I thought
it was Don't you think, Chank that it's like you kind of pushing
violence if you just quote Charlie Kirk in your titles? Chank,
don't you think that's really
Well, they're all quotes so far. I don't know if they're all
quotes overall, but >> Kirk gives pigish advice to high
school girls. Ex employee exposes Charlie Kirk's grift. Charlie
Kirk embarrasses himself. Charlie Kirk's brain melts explaining
antivax conspiracy. Charlie Kirk rants about >> Okay. Yeah.
I don't know if Dave's confused. Dave is very confused. Okay.
Dave's like, "Wait, it made way me way more money to like shift
over the right-wing and all my opinions went with the money."
So like, why does Chank still have his same opinions? Why does
he like disagree with Charlie politically? Doesn't he know there's
more money over here? It's like, yeah, no, Chank is just he disagrees
with Charlie. Just doesn't think anything Charlie says is correct.
Obviously,
that's what's happening. Wait, why why would he say bad things
about Charlie? There's so much money in saying good things about
Charlie. >> About women in their 30s. Charlie Clerk Kirk
has literally no clue how the real world works. Charlie Kirk
gets triggered, declines appearance over pronouns. Charlie Kirk
doubles down on women hating backlash. I am telling you peers,
Charlie Kirk was one of the best human beings I ever met. He
did not have a bone of racism.
this is
the most transparent grifting from Dave Rubin. Listen,
I swear can Russia just pay this guy again so I don't have to
see him. If Russia could pay this guy to just off that would
be incredible.
At least when Russia was paying him, he was too lazy to put out
any content. I didn't have to see his face.
This loser,
>> Or anything else in his body. But liars lie and they
jin up otherwise good people. From the little bit we know about
this shooter, he had a stable household. He was going to college.
He was fine. We'll find out where he got radicalized. But please,
please let's not pretend we don't know where this stuff is coming
from. And please let's not pretend that this thing is going both
ways because it is absolutely not. I also have a Well, you know
what, Jank, I'll ask you a question directly, actually. Do you
think Charlie wanted to be martyed? Do you think Charlie wanted
to be martyed? Do you think Charlie wanted to be Yes or no? >> How
in the is that the question you're ch, do you think Charlie wanted
to be? Yeah, this is the appropriate response. Yes, this is like
actually the appropriate response. this stupid question. Thank
you, Shank. This is literally the only This is literally the
only response right here. Yeah. Thank you. Yes. >> Of course
not. What kind of assign question is that? >> You Oh, you
don't you don't cuz that's pretty interesting cuz here's a video
of you Jank talking when Charlie was at a breakfast for these
guys and and they don't deserve it. Um, but I do also want to
point out as they're in the middle of crying now. Although Charlie
was smiling ear to ear throughout the entire video, thinking,
"Yes,
I'm now the victim and I'll get to claim that my rights have
been abridged." >> Did you catch the beginning of that,
Jake? What >> a [__] >> Dude, Dave Rubin
sucks so badly.
>> You can't take advantage of victimhood if you're literally
dead. >> Oh, sorry. This would be from before. This would
be from like a a different talk he was doing or something,
>> Yeah. But it's he's trying to point out that Jenk is
is saying that Charlie Kirk wants to be the victim, but him like
wanting the victimhood brownie points is not to say that, yeah,
Charlie Kirk wanted to die or wanted to get assassinated for
his political ideology. >> Dude, I can't operate I can't
>> I can't operate on Dave Rubin's level. I had no idea
what the he was saying just now. Listen, >> Jesus. That's
Hold on. >> And and they don't deserve it. Um, but I do
also want to point out, as in they're in the middle of crying
now, although Charlie was smiling ear to ear throughout the entire
video, thinking,
I'm now the victim." And I'll get the claim that my rights have
been abridged. >> Did you catch the beginning of that,
>> Listen, we'll do it again. No, I didn't. And that's
totally out of No, we're not going to do it again. Totally out
of context. I don't even know what the hell you're talking No,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Listen, listen, brother.
Is that what you're trying to do, loser? Jesus Christ. >> No,
no, no. I'm trying to do consiliation. What people like you >> look
at the last two things of your the last two guests. >> Piers.
Piers.
>> Piers. No. What they said was we should have reconciliation,
but it is not without any contrition. Right. It's not without
a Maya. Charlie was accosted by Antifa at a breakfast in Philadelphia.
And the video that I just played is you with a cartoon of him
as Charlie Brown saying that he would love to be martyed so he
could be the victim. Well, I guarantee you his wife who now doesn't
have a husband and his kids who don't
did not want him to be you just played isn't what I exactly what
you said, brother said it was. >> Let's do it again. >> No,
it isn't. We just heard it. We just heard it. All right. So,
you know, let's do it again. >> Cut this crap out. >> Come
on. Do it again. >> Pierce, can we talk about reality?
This is something he's going >> Dude, this guy this
this Dave Rubin guy.
And hold on, we got a link to Chank doing like a response. Chank
did a statement afterwards. A lot of people on the left didn't
like Charlie Kirk for what the Oh, wait. What they thought was
hate speech? Okay, but what's more hateful than murdering someone?
So if you Oh, this is uh Oh, so if you're oppo that opposed him
for that reason, shouldn't you be even more outraged at what
happened to him, which is was pure hate? And that is exactly
how I feel. I was outraged by some of the things Charlie said,
but I'm infinitely more outraged by his murder. I thought he
said negative things about Muslims. My offense at those words
are nothing compared to his death. You'd have to be blind not
to see that. Okay, so it's him talking about Charlie saying some
bad things about Muslims. Got it. Got it. >> Going back
to like 10 years. >> Well, I think I think should be
what I said there. >> And they don't deserve it. >> It
allows for easy martyrdom for these guys and they don't deserve
it. That was when Antifa was going after him at a breakfast.
So, let's let Jake respond to >> No, that was about words,
you [__] Okay. Jesus Christ, man. All right. So,
>> easy to reality. Okay.
>> Shut up. Let's get to reality. Okay. So, your last two
guests while pretending to be consiliatory,
one of them started talking about me and started talking about
blood on the hands. And then this idiot brings out a clip from
10 years ago that's about words and is pretending it has to do
with violence. No show in America has called for nonviolence
more than the Young Turks has over. Hey, can I talk after being
accused of terrible things that I didn't come within a million
miles of doing? Who Who did Charlie invite to have these conver?
>> I wish I wish Shank would ask him like, "How much did
Putin pay you to do this? How much Putin paying you to do this
right now? Just throw in his face every >> Me, why did
he invite >> It doesn't even make sense.
Jenk is literally obviously it's not saying that he wants to
be he can't benefit from being a victim if he's dead and he's
saying that he doesn't deserve easy martyrdom
or whatever it's called. >> Well, what Chen's talking about
is like he's saying that Charlie Kirk's like getting accosted
somewhere out, right? And Chen's saying, "Oh, he's like acting
like a martyr. He's acting like he's the victim here. Let him
be the victim, right?" But that's what Chen's talking about is
like when they're shouting at him, when they're not letting him
speak, and when they're when they're like shutting him down,
is he gets to act like the victim, then he gets to be the martyr.
That's that's what the clip's about. It's not about like, oh,
this guy got shot and now he gets to be the martyr. He's so happy.
>> It's like not related. >> Oh, so wait, I think
I'm putting it together. Dave Rubin is trying to say that Jenk
was complaining that this is giving Charlie Kirk easy martyrdom
and that he should have it the difficult way.
be well kind of basically that like oh why did you talk about
him being a martyr or whatever right like he's he's saying martyr
means getting killed and Shank's like no I like obviously there's
like a martyr's complex right like you are you're a constant
victim a perpetual victim like he's trying to take it literally
he's trying to use that meaning to take it literally in like
>> it's such an old clip to how old did he say it was >> Shank
said 10 years I don't know if it's 10 years but >> I don't
even know which one I can believe some reason they both seem
like snakes to me. >> Okay. I just had to look up murder
complex to see if it exists. It does exist. [__]
you. Sorry, somebody chat. >> You if I'm >> saying
persecution complex. No, no, no, no, no. Okay. I don't I don't
like Dave Rubin and I don't agree with what he's doing here,
but he's making the point that like, hey, if you tell your audience
this guy doesn't deserve to to get like the victimhood of a martyr
the easy way. You are that is you're saying something to your
audience. >> Wait, I don't think he said that though. I
think he's saying that like I I don't think that's what Chen
said. We should find the clip maybe. I think it was like he's
talking about how he's act he's just he's so psyched because
now he gets to be a victim >> and that's all that it seemed
to be >> but he said something about getting it the easy
way
which means that you don't actually like you just have to have
words said to you >> get the well you get >> but
I don't think he implied that he shouldn't here we can
um Shank Charlie >> and this is not to say I don't think
at all that Shank from TYT is the person who inspired somebody
to take this dude. That's not what I'm saying at all. But if
we're going to talk and we're going to scrutinize people for
their rhetoric, like there's obviously something to scrutinize
here. It just sucks. It feels like everyone gets called out by
like a person. And so you put yourself in a position to defend
somebody just because the person calling them out is like a
>> I just have a bunch of conservative calling Charlie
Kirk martyr now. I can't find the clip. Easy martyrdom for the
>> There we go. Here's the uh Oh, this is Dave Rubin posting
it though. Me >> deserve it. Um
>> it allows for easy martyrdom for these guys and and
they don't deserve it. Um but I do also want to point out as
in they're in the middle of crying now. Although Charlie was
smiling ear to ear throughout the entire video. Think >> they
don't deserve it. As in hold on he's saying easy martyrdom for
these guys and he's like they don't deserve the harassment. They
don't deserve the harassment. Not that they don't deserve martyrdom.
They They don't deserve the harassment.
That's what he's saying. I'm almost positive. Like this allows
for easy martyrdom for these guys. Not that they deserve it.
That's what he's >> I play >> for easy martyrdom
for these guys and and they don't deserve it. Um but I do also
want to point out as in they're in the middle of crying now.
>> Okay. So you're saying that him saying they don't deserve
it was him slipping in like a disavowel.
>> Yeah. It doesn't mean they don't they deserve to get
like harassed. Whatever the happening to them. >> Okay.
Then the way that Dave Rubin is presenting it is just like
insanely dishonest.
>> Yeah. And I've never like Shanks Shanks like kind of
unhinged, but I've never heard him do anything close to being
like somebody should get these guys. I feel like if Shank's going
to threaten somebody, he'll actually threaten to fight people
directly, right? I think I think Shank's more like that. >> But
that's the thing. That's what I hate. I don't want to ever do
the thing where it's like, "No, Jen would never do this. I I
feel like he would he would probably say something that
>> encourages violence. You know what I >> I don't
know if I've ever heard that, but like I I would need I guess
to say that I would need some actual like proof >> Time
here. >> Either side of it. >> Doing anything physical
is not the right direction. And I agree with um >> so I
would go back a little more >> into silence.
Now I I want to be clear one more time here. Uh doing anything
physical is not the right direction. And I agree with um Philip
Wagman who wrote for the Washington Examiner that it allows for
easy martyrdom for these
>> I mean, >> oh my goodness, Dave Rubin's a complete
>> context makes Dave Rubin look like op. He is literally
telling people don't kill anyone cuz then they have easy
>> Yeah. Is it >> Listen, I did such a I gave the
most good faith to what the [__] you could be saying
about Jenk.
>> that is insane, >> dude. It's uh that's pretty
crazy. That's pretty nuts. Dave Rubin, everybody. What a
Oh, I've got words for this guy. This guy is gross. This guy
is the worst.
That's wild.
>> So bad when it comes to these issues. No, it's because
Charlie and I understood that we could vehemently disagree. We
could
>> David, let me speak.
>> so we understood that we could have vehement disagreement
and we often did. And look, guys, you're
but without
any of those videos being a white
>> No, I'm not. No, I'm not. Because Dave, what you're
doing is Dave, will you let me talk? >> You think he was
a white supremacist? Was Charlie a white supremacist?
>> dude. Dave Dave Rubin, >> our FBI director thinks
he was. >> Oh, maybe. Oh, maybe. Um, Dave Rubin is like
actually
picking up Charlie Kirk's corpse and trying to beat Chank to
death with it. I don't know why. Okay.
Like I it's so disgusting that he has no actual argument here
and he's just going to try to use the outrage driven by Charlie's
like assassination to make to to like with Shank here and get
somebody to watch him.
This is like disgusting. It's like a totally disgusting. Like
there's a level of grifting. Like this person's a total grifter.
I've never seen this person give like a genuine opinion. They're
a total liar. Total grifter. Like I don't think they'd use I
don't think they'd use somebody's like death to try to like just
make I don't even know what Dave Rubin's doing.
It's gross, man. >> Like at least I >> Wait, what
do you mean you don't know? There's so much misinformation being
pushed out. It has to be
um like paid
>> I don't know. I I mean I just I don't >> You think
Dave Stop. You think Dave Rubin is pulling up to a Piers Morgan
panel with his clips handed to the producers ready to go off
the cuff? >> He didn't hand it to the producer. He played
it on his phone.
No, I don't think he's doing it off the cuff. But I don't think
you need like foreign money to get a clip before you go on a
panel with somebody either. Um, he could be taking foreign money.
I think he is. Right. I think he's taking like Hungarian money.
>> I want to say >> I'm not saying it's foreign money,
but I'm It's paid propaganda. >> Yeah. I mean, it's dude,
they're they're just Sorry. I guess what I'm really hinting at
is like there should be there need to be lines for people. Like
lines you can't cross. Lines you can't cross and come back from.
And this guy's like >> he's crossed it like how many times?
>> He's totally brain. I don't know. Yeah, it's unlist.
Well, you if you're not going to let me answer, what the hell
is the point of
>> Okay, listen. >> Well, you won't. >> Do
I still disagree with the things that Charlie said? Of course
I do. I'm not changing my opinion on that. And all the titles
that you just read were very normal political disagreements in
none of the titles were there. Call for violence cuz there never
is on the Young Turks. And I hope what happened to Charlie. I
met his wife. This is a human being. You we look guys, there's
two things that I propose. You guys can go >> Those headlines
imply that Charlie.
No. Now I talk. Now I talk. Enough with the accusing and then
not letting me talk. Okay. So, >> dude, I listen. If Chen
is going to threaten violence, okay,
come over. Come back to uh the Republican National Convention,
Dave. See what happens. See what happens. >> This whole
>> for Chank Chen should say that. I don't think that Chank
Chank's the guy who will throw fists. Okay. >> I both sides
are blind. You know, we and Piers, you know this better than
anyone. I call out Biden. I say, "All right, Democrats, are you
crazy?" He's obviously old. He's obviously lost his faculties,
right? And now this absurdity about how the right are all angels.
Are are we kidding? You guys didn't see January 6. You didn't
see them attacking cops, raiding the capital, chanting, "Hang
Mike Pence. Hang Mike Pence." But that leads to my point. Not
that the right is more guilty. And I'm sickened by the trend
that has now appeared on the left of violence. I'm sickened by
it. So I'm proposing two things, guys. Well, I'm not No way should
we ever shut down speech. No way. Not right-wing speech, not
leftwing speech. You don't shut it down with the government and
you don't shut it down with violence. So, first thing is easy.
The second one is hard. The first one is on all of our shows
as we do every day. Call for nonviolence. The minute you see
someone saying something violent, say, "Don't do that. That is
unacceptable. That is not who we are on the left. That is not
who we are on the right. That is not who we are as Americans."
You can say anything you want. For example, did Charlie say?
>> I still like 10% want him to punch Dave Dave Rubin in
the face. Okay. 10% I still wanted him to punch Dave in the >> Um
but sure. >> Sure. Sorry I cut you off just to say that.
What were you saying? >> I'm just laughing. Jen is like
rule number one, see something, say something. Call out people
who are saying something violent.
>> okay. Perfect. The people on the right are doing that.
They're seeing something and they're saying something to everyone's
employers.
>> Probably be a little bit more specific about that one.
Yeah. >> Things that were anti-Muslim. He did. Did I still
talk to him? Yes. And I got heat for that. But guys, we're never
going to convince each other if we never talk to one another.
And now if we start each other, it's madness. We There's nothing
wrong with disagreement, but there's something terribly wrong
with violence and shutting down conversations. And then the hard
one. I just think the left and the right. There is no such thing.
Hold on. Last thing. Last thing. Last thing. There's no such
thing as the left or the right. There is only ex There are people
that are a giant range. And we explain this on the Young Turks
all the time about >> Dude, I'm having a hard time not
using slurs for this guy right now. He's accusing Chen of crocodile
tears. Brother, you grab you like clip chimp this guy. try to
use Charlie Kirk's death to like take a shot at him on a Piers
Morgan panel.
Like in terms of disingenuous behavior, you get to cast zero
stones. You are a complete piece of Shut the up. >> The
right-wing, which is guys, they are they radical right? There
are, right? But are they the entirety of all of the Trump voters?
Of course not. There's so many good Americans who voted for Trump,
who by the way, some of them voted for Obama before, some of
them voted for Bernie before. Same thing on the left. This guy's
a lunatic. Are there extreme leftwingers? By the way, the clip
that you showed Pier >> Oh, that would be a man.
Um, any any heaven that Charlie Kirk could have gotten into,
you won't be welcome in, Dave. And I take solace in that fact.
Okay. I could be wrong about religion, but I take solace in the
fact that whatever heaven Charlie could get into, you couldn't
possibly enter. So, go [__] yourself.
>> There's no prominent Democrat or leftwingers on there.
But that clip sickened me. It sickened me. So is >> okay
but no but
elements in the world but hang on
hang on
but hang on you mentioned that and in fact there are clips though
of highprofile people saying that stuff. Matthew Dao got fired
by MB MSNBC within minutes literally of saying this uh on the
night that Charlie got killed. >> Talk to me about the
environment um in which a shooting like this happens. >> Yeah
and again emphasize what you just emphasized. We don't know any
the full details of this that we don't know if this was a supporter
shooting their gun off in celebration or so we have no idea about
this. But following up what what was just said he's been one
of the most divisive especially divisive younger figures in this
who is >> supporters shooting the gun off in
>> the talking. >> Yeah. And again emphasize what
you just emphasized. We don't know any full details of this that
we don't know if this was a supporter shooting their gun off
in celebration or so. We have no idea about this. But following
up, >> wait, how quickly? When was he saying this? Maybe
he actually didn't know,
>> What was just said, he's been one of the most divisive
>> after the shooting. >> Yeah. So, and then he says
he's been one of the most divisive, which, you know, in the moments
right after the shooting, I can see why you wouldn't want to
do that. especially divisive younger figures in this who is constantly
sort of pushing this sort of hate speech or sort of aimed at
certain groups and I always go back to hateful thoughts lead
to hateful words which then lead to hateful actions and I think
that's the environment we're in that that people just you can't
stop with these sort of >> okay I'll say descriptively
I don't think he's incorrect
this is pretty much the worst time you could ever possibly say
this. Okay, this is this is the like worst time you could ever
do this. There's you can have something that's like descriptively
correct, sure,
but dude, you you have to know you got to read the room a little
bit of awful thoughts you have and then saying these awful words
and not expect awful action >> cuz this is this is saying
like Yeah.
>> What? Saying awful words and not expect awful actions.
It's saying that like so you can make this argument that hey
if you if you you have free speech but if you're going to use
hate speech you know in certain places at certain times you can
reasonably expect to get like clapped back on doesn't make it
correct right doesn't make it correct for people to use violence
on you but you you have to understand that it can lead to some
actions right you could say that but when you say it right after
this guy got shot it's going to seem like you're saying of course
he got shot I'm okay with him getting shot he knew what he was
doing right he's like emphasizing izing all the wrong parts.
This is not good. This is like a really dumb thing to do to be
honest.
>> And I think that's the environment we're in that that
people just you can't stop with these sort of awful thoughts
you have and then saying these awful words and not expect awful
actions to take place. And that's the unfortunate environment
we're in. >> In other words, Chen, you know, he had it
coming. And uh I I >> No, he's not saying he had it coming.
He's not saying that it there's no I can read it. Okay, I can
understand that that guy's trying to say that >> he's saying
don't go
like what is what is that like how to not get advice that people
do after somebody gets it's like bad timing
like this isn't the time to lecture on how to
>> engage you check your drink >> on dates or something
like that. Yeah, but if you if you said like, "Wait, you you
left your drink unattended." And then it's like that's that's
now somebody's come along and going, "Wait, why did you ask that?
Are you saying she deserved it?" It's like, "No, he's not saying
that." He's like making a point that might be something you could
analyze, but also like the worst possible time here, brother.
What are you doing?
Uh
yeah. Yeah,
>> I found that despicable. I said it in the moment. He
then got fired and quite rightly but there were lots of he said
play stupid games win stupid prizes. He said something along
those lines but there's no like oh there's there's no
with with play stupid games win stupid prizes and there was one
other one somebody said oh that he was had it coming. Those are
both implying like a moral waiting there that they deserved it
that there was some like deserving of it which is not something
I think that guy said. I don't think he ever made the point that
like oh you deserve it right although he might think that. But
I'm not sure >> of other high-profile people actually who
weren't just Tik Tockers saying bad stuff. Just whole fire panel
for a moment. I'm being joined now by Republican Congresswoman
Lauren Bobbert. Uh Lauren, thank you very much indeed for rejoining
me on uncensored.
What not seen on camera? Lauren Boowbert her boyfriend off on
camera while on Piers Morgan right now. Okay. Not appearing here,
but it is obviously happening.
What impact is Charlie Kirk's murder going to have on the ability
of political figures, either politicians? Why are you guys spamming
question marks? Do you guys not know the Lauren Boowbert lore?
>> It was in a movie theater. >> It wasn't a movie
theater. Wait, do do people not know that lore
that Lauren Bilbert got kicked out of a movie theater for her
husband off like in the Oh, it was a musical. >> I believe
it was her husband. >> Dude, that makes it way worse. It
was that Beetlejuice. Yeah, I'm pretty sure it wasn't her husband,
by the way. This guy was like grabbing her tit and she was starting
to like jerk him off through his shorts and they got kicked out.
Okay. Yeah, it wasn't her husband then.
Or political commentators to go about their business talking
to members of the public without massively increasing their security.
I mean, have you, for example, had to up your security since
his >> uh Somebody said, "I can't believe there's video
of a United States senator a dude off." Uh, yeah, there is not
video of that unless I'm unaware. She's a representative. She's
in the House of Representatives. Okay.
>> Well, first, thanks for having me on, Pierce, to talk
about my friend Charlie and uh the ramifications of this. I I
I feel like our first amendment rights were assassinated um or
at least attempted to uh just a couple of days ago and has certainly
been difficult. Um and conversations of security for those of
us uh who are uh in in the public eye have have definitely increased.
Uh they've been increasing all year. I even talked to my Democrat
colleagues. Jared Moscowitz is someone who uh has also received
death threats and um even a man parked outside his home uh where
where his wife and children are and uh so we have increased some
security. I don't believe it's enough. Uh I I think that we need
more. >> I can't believe so many people don't know about
Lauren B Bober that dude off in the in that theater.
That's like crazy that nobody knows that. or there's that's crazy
that like it seems like half of the chat didn't know
>> or and um well the ability that we have right now the
resources that we have right now uh won't cover uh what we need
but uh it's not going to slow us down. I'm not cancelling events.
I'm continuing to go exactly where I was scheduled to be and
and talk to folks. Uh it would be a dishonor to Charlie if I
if I were to close my mouth and sit back and quit now. We have
got to continue forward in in this uh movement that he really
pioneered the way for and uh and continue to speak truth. Uh
Charlie would bring on his advers.
>> Charlie pioneered literally 0% of anything he did. Charlie
is like the last mover, the last dude off the bus in all cases.
Okay. He took Ben Shapiro's [__] from 15 years ago
and combined it with Steven Crowder from 12 years ago, put them
together and created something stupid that he is just totally
copying from other people. What do you mean he pioneered? Shut
up.
>> Folks who disagreed with him uh and and and have that
dialogue, have that debate in that. >> Why was Charlie
so popular actually? He sit um I think he was I don't man if
you ask me. Okay.
If you ask me, I don't think he was. I think he was kind of like
a made guy that didn't really actually do anything well and and
he was basically just getting like f but apparently with like
Christians all over the US, he's actually quite popular like
with young Christians and and people like kind of doing the return
to tradition thing. So I I it's way outside of like my knowledge
base. Okay. But to me, he was like not really This is what I
thought Substance was. I didn't think he was very good at um
he's approachable to educated virgin evangelicals. Okay. I just
thought he was good at networking. He is very good at networking.
He's very good at um at making like at at building a network.
Yes, he was very good at that. Okay. >> Discussion and
give them a platform even certainly Charlie has given me a platform
over the years, but he gave folks who completely opposed his
point of view a platform as well to express that. And and I believe
that through his vision and his faith, we will continue to see
that with the millions of young people that he has touched. I
I hope that there are 10 million Charlie >> I'm going to
be real, okay? I don't Charlie Kirk a lot, but is there no surgery
to get your tooth to gum ratio fixed? Is there nothing?
Looks like Terrell sucks.
You can get your there's like your toothbone is under your gum
so you can get your gum like lasered off so more of the tooth
is exposed. >> You guys ever see Terrell Suggs? You ever
see Terrell Suggs? Sherry. Oh, Terrell Suggs got surgery. Oh,
dude. Terrell Suggs got some surgery. Or maybe Hold on. Yeah,
Terrell Suggs got some surgery at some point. But Charlie's got
like Terrell Suggs syndrome.
It's crazy. Look at this
guy's a Baltimore Raven. This is like what I think is going on
with Charlie Kirk. I mean, I guess I guess it's kind of a moot
point at this point. Never mind.
>> Yeah, I guess it's kind of a moot point. Sorry. Anyway,
>> I believe that through his vision and his faith, we
will continue to see that with the millions of young people that
he has touched. I I hope that there are 10 million Charlie Kirks
who are born from this moment. Uh but certainly the the political
violence, it has to stop. And we've been saying this for for
years now. I have we you could have compilation after compilation
of Democrat politicians saying uh to get in their faces, to take
them behind the barn and and and and punch them, punch them in
the face and and all of these things uh by elected leaders. You
are called to lead and you're telling your constituents, your
voters, and your followers to actually be aggressive uh physically.
And this is just unacceptable. This is not something that you
hear uh from my conservative colleagues and you know if they
do say it I absolutely condemn that. Uh but this is a time for
truth and for standing up and of course there are concerns. Listen
Pierce, we had a mandatory instaff meeting that was called by
the sergeant-at-arms at the House of Representatives. Uh they
flew to Colorado to meet with all of my district staff. >> She's
just lying. Trump said it. Wait, what? What are you guys even
talking about? elected leaders. You are called to lead and you're
telling your constituents, your voters and your followers to
actually be aggressive uh physically and this is just unacceptable.
This is not something that you hear uh from my conservative colleagues
and >> take his coat. Someone someone take his coat. You
guys remember that?
>> That's how that guy started off. >> There may
be a remnant. Oh no, it's only the same people coming down the
street. No, there's a remnant. Yeah, he's right there. I believe
it's like what is this? This is in Wisconsin, right? I think.
Oh, ver Burlington, Vermont. This is the middle of winter. Okay.
It's like - 40 out or minus I don't know minus 10. I don't know
what it is in
American. Okay. >> Okay. Yeah. Throw them out. Throw them
out into the cold. You know,
>> don't give them their coat. >> No coats. No coats.
Confiscate their coat. You know, you can't win. By the way, just
to finish, I was I had one word left. Iraq. And nobody heard
it because these characters.
>> Yeah, the people were like protesting his thing. He's
like, "Take their coats. Take their coats. Throw them out in
the
I wonder how that happened. Seems like it was through physical
violence, but Or maybe not. I don't know. Look how much more.
Yeah, he was a different animal in 2016. Okay. 2016. I understood
exactly how he got elected. 2024. This guy's run
He also said in another instance to knock them out and he would
pay their legal fees. Oh, yeah. Go knock that guy. Yeah. Go.
>> Yeah. 100%. >> And you know, if they do live videos
of him have his pinky randomly disappearing, too. >> Yeah,
it's crazy. >> Very different. >> He's doing ma he's
doing magic tricks while giving presentations. He's a whole different
person. Okay. How is he doing this? He's doing illusions. >> Absolutely
condemn that. Uh but this is a time for truth and for standing
up. And of course, there are concerns. Listen, Pierce, we had
a mandatory instaff meeting that was called by the Sergeant-at-Arms
at the House of Representatives. uh they flew to Colorado to
meet with all of my district staff and um it was announced in
that meeting that I am number three on their list for targeted
members of Congress and uh you know we certainly have have increased
uh security uh since then but it it hasn't stopped and even to
add to that this week I would have never expected any kind of
calls coming into my office or >> on whose list the sergeant
at at arms. the sergeant-at-arms or sergeant-at-arms
in Congress, I don't know, >> emails of of a threatening
nature. And we have sent in more threats to Capitol police and
FBI this week than in in the past couple of months and maybe
even longer than that. And uh so, you know, when we're hearing
things like Charlie Kirk uh rightfully was murdered and you should
be too, um this is what has to stop. And I would have never expected
Wait, who said Charlie Kirk was rightfully murdered and you should
be too? These people just like make things up in the middle of
their speech and slip them in and then expect us to just go,
"Yeah, it sucks when people say that." No, I'm listening. actually
>> Americans to continue down that path. Be joyful that
such an amazing Christian faithfilled father, friend, man, leader
uh was assassinated uh executed in front of our faces and and
they would continue with that rhetoric and rejoice in it. This
is a disgusting dark time and I hope that we could bring light
and joy and true unity. We don't need an enemy to unite around.
We live in America which is the greatest country. Sorry. Uh,
but this is the great I'm not sorry. This is the greatest country
and we have so much to be grateful for and honor and respect
one another that that alone.
>> I don't know. >> Should be what unites us.
>> You do know. Pause. Sorry. I get it. You're Canadian.
You don't understand what the she just did there. >> Yeah,
she's American. She's rude as [__] Why the [__]
did she do this? >> No, no, no. Shut up. She's American.
She's acknowledging it's the greatest country and then she apologizes
cuz she's talking to a British person. Why would you ever apologize?
Shove it in his face. We left you because we're better than you.
That is the most unAmerican thing she ever did. >> Bongerburgger
fight. Let's go. >> Thank you for that. Uh very fasc I
mean disturbing actually that you've had more threats since Charlie
Kirk was murdered than you have done for many months. I found
that a particularly disturbing uh thing that you revealed there,
but I appreciate you coming on our sensor. Thank you very much.
>> Thank you, Pierce. >> Too many Americans in the
chat who think what Cherry just said was based. Okay.
>> Too many
>> right now. >> Panel. I mean, Batia,
the thing we haven't discussed in all this, I guess, is uh the
guns. Obviously, every time there's a gun uh a big action of
gun violence, there's a big debate about it. It's well known
that I was when I was at CNN got into many debates about this.
I got into debates with Charlie about guns. In fact, he tweeted
um something which you know now you look at it and you you sort
of wse when you read that. Hey Pierers Morgan, I thought guns
don't save lives. Is Pierce Morgan starking right now? What the
what? Pierce, why would you do this? What the Piers? Hey Asminold,
get this fired. You see him pulling up these tweets and making
fun of Charlie. We get Piers Morgan. Get him off the internet.
get him off YouTube right now. Take his YouTube channel right
now. >> And actually, he was talking about an Uber driver
who'd had um a concealed carry weapon which which saved his life.
Um so Charlie and I debated guns. We came at it from different
perspectives.
And um I respected that and he did. He then came on my show to
talk about other things. So we didn't let that mean we couldn't
debate things. Where are we with guns in America? I I sort of
felt I learned the lesson when I was debating with the NRA and
so on. This is an American problem that can only be resolved
by Americans. It's not a UK problem. And actually, we used to
all have guns in Britain and we gave them all up. So, we don't
have a gun violence problem here. Certainly nothing that could
be compared to the United States. But, you know, there's always
a, you know, this is not the right time to discuss it, but people
are discussing it. What do you feel about the guns debate in
this? >> Oh gosh, I feel like it's so irrelevant. I mean,
one side of the political aisle in America is heavily armed and
it's the other side that commits the vast majority of political
violence. You >> see, this person is like a total grifter.
You know, there's a tacit admission from the left that their
side is the violent side because if somebody, god forbid, if
a big left-wing influencer, god forbid, was killed, what they
would be doing immediately is boarding up every single major
city in America because there would
>> no nobody gives up, dude. You
>> be rioting and looting. People would die. We know that
tens if not hundreds of people died during the BLM riot. >> Dude,
there's like a they they don't understand. It's like there's
a systemic issue with George Floyd that had been boiling over
that there was like a movement building behind that for years
and years and years and years. There's no movement building behind
these people. There's nothing like that. >> And obviously
and there was like an immediate like civil unrest just for the
fact of like lockdowns. Everyone stopped. They were home restless
for days, right? They were going to be irritable and quick to
anger.
>> And basically, for some reason, they're cool to go outside
for this. So, listen, we have to riot. Save this guy's life.
Also, for me to just go outside and see other people. >> I
guarantee some people went to those things just so they could
like sit down and have like a beer with some friends, okay? They
just brought a cooler. They're like, "Oh, isn't it nice that
we could hang out out here right now? Let's >> None of
that has happened. And none of that is expected to happen despite
the fact that the right whose avatar was just murdered in cold
blood is heavily armed. Right? So there is this tacit understanding
from the left even as they call the right the source of all the
political violence and fascists and and what have you that actually
the right will not pick up their arms and turn on their leftist
neighbors. Right? They rely on the forbearance of their conservative
neighbors who are much more heavily armed not to actually take
revenge. And we all know that this is
>> Yeah. Just like I Dude, could you imagine who thinks
of things this way? Listen, listen guys, you should just be happy
that your conservative neighbor doesn't come and kill you because
Charlie Kirk was shot. Okay? Doesn't matter if you follow politics.
Doesn't matter what your engagement is. All right? Just be happy
this guy doesn't come and kill you cuz they took Charlie away
from us. Are you saying, dude? What the [__] are
you talking about?
>> They just won't admit it. It is so amazing to sit here
and have people bring up case after case after case that has
been like thoroughly debunked. You know, just because Josh Shapiro
is a Democrat doesn't mean the person who tried to him was a
Republican. That guy did it. He said because Josh Shapiro is
his Palestinian friends. Okay. And we have cases like that again
and again. They have to keep going back to January 6th which
as Vince pointed out no one was except Ashley Babbot who was
>> again bunch of fat manga people died though. one of
the protesters to compare a meme posted of a Halloween costume
to people actually saying the things that murderers then used
to justify their like the guy who killed that couple outside
the museum in in DC or like this killer who killed Charlie saying
the exact same things you hear from the most prominent Democrats
is facitious. It is
don't think she's using facicious correctly at all >> to
compare an actual justification for murder that turns into murder
with a a photo that gets posted. And this is why conservatives
are so frustrated because they know that even as the left is
demonizing them, the left is
>> tacitly acknowledging that they're not
>> facicious means like farcical, right? Treating serious
issues with deliberately inappropriate humor. Flippant. Uh yeah,
I know it's not
>> What's the horoscope? >> Quad quad word that she
used instead of >> That means daily. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh >> I can't even remember what it was. >> She's
like a female president Sunday.
I think he uses those words correctly.
>> She's just like wordy for no reason. >> Quotidian.
Yeah, quotidian. >> Danger from their conservative
>> Well, Lewis, I know you've got to go. Vinnie's had to
go as well, sadly. Um Lewis, you've got to go. said just just
final words from you. Have you been influenced at all by anything
you've heard tonight? >> I I I sort of feel and maybe we
all are. Maybe this is the problem. Um appears as if I'm living
in in in a different world here. A world where the only invective
that we ever hear, the only hostile language, the only violent
language and indeed call to arms come from one side of the political
debate. I would just go back to this point. US government figures
show that a majority. >> Dude, sorry. I just have to pull
this up really quickly. How does Eerite keep blaming people for
happening to her? All these different groups, all these different
groups did this. If if Phil remains knew me, you'd know that
leftist doxed me, doxed my parents, swatted me, email my mother,
threats and lies, doxed my brother, mass reported and banned
my YouTube.
She has no evidence for any of these things she's saying that
these people were leftists. Zero. Unless you want to say Unless
you want to say the Sunday stuff was toxic and then she could
do like the the doxy thing was Sunday, but I don't even know
that that was I don't Why does she just keep
Do you think you just pile lies on top of lies on top of lies
and just never have a problem? >> Why does she
Never mind. I This is just like a really gross thing. I hate
when people do this on the right and the left where it's like
here are all of the terrible things that have ever happened to
me. Do you even know how hard my life is? >> I don't know.
Like if you're going to do that, also tell me that you're on
the verge of killing yourself. Otherwise, I don't even believe
that you're struggling >> in a video game. >> Yeah.
In a video game. >> I just I literally don't know why.
There's like eight different groups of people who are responsible
for all of these things and she just like throws them down to
weigh people down wherever she can. I don't know why.
I have no idea why. It's just
>> Kind of mean. >> For therapeutic purposes. Anyway,
>> all right. Oh, why didn't I just close this? Back to
back to peersity
of political violence.
>> Politically related violent incidents actually come
from the right, not the left. Now, I'm not sat here saying that
there isn't a problem on the left. I've been the first one quite
literally to say that. But by definition, if there are politically
inspired violent incidents on the right, then what is causing
those? Are they all just nutters? They all they all just mad
or how can it be that the left left-wing ones are the ones who
are inspired by language? Something must be happening and causing
the rightwing violence and so by definition presumably that must
be must be something that is happening in terms of the language
of the other side. No, and just let me finish and just I mean
I think we heard from Kristen earlier as well when he said the
left have embied this idea that to get what you want you are
able and should be able to use violence. I mean, come on. Yeah,
go back to January the 6th because MAGA at that moment quite
literally decided to use violence to overturn an election result.
And let's just talk about violent language as well for a second
here. From the very, very top, Donald Trump, fight like hell.
If you don't fight like hell, you're not going to have a country
anymore. Rudy Giuliani, let's have trial by combat. Republican
Representative Mo Brooks, today is the day American patriots
start. >> Wait, Mel Brooks is a Republican representative.
what the around taking names and kicking on the Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer kidnapping plot. Instead of condemning it, didn't
condemn it. What did Trump do? He said maybe it was a problem.
Maybe it wasn't. She locked down her state. Even on Mitch McConnell,
his own Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell truth on Truth
Social, Trump said McConnell had a death wish for supporting
bipartisan legislation. If that's not legitimizing violence,
then I don't know what it is. >> Constantine, your response
to that? I I I have to agree with Lewis. He is living in a different
reality, one that has no connection to actual reality. Uh what's
wrong with
what I've just said? You're comparing somebody saying fight like
hell in the context of a political campaign
what I explained earlier.
Can I speak? Are you capable of listening to an alternative point
of view or do you have listen? >> Well, shut up then. >> Shut
up and listen if you're capable of it. Now, you can't compare
somebody saying fight like hell in the context of a political
campaign with what I explained earlier, which is when you call
people campaign was over. >> Shut up and listen to an alternative
opinion. Why is
>> just stop stop arguing with me. Don't come on this panel
to argue with me. >> That you people have a complete inability
to listen to opinions that you don't like. Why can't you just
sit there and actually hear what I'm saying?
>> I'm waiting. >> You can't com Oh my god. You can't
compare somebody saying fight like hell with somebody explaining
that the country is an imminent threat of a fascist takeover
because an imminent threat of a fascist takeover is something
that would actually legitimize you picking up a rifle and heading
to the front line. So when you and Jenk and people like that
call people you don't like farr right hard right and fascist
you are creating an environment in which some crazy people yes
of course they're crazy will feel that they're entitled to use
violence to prevent the fake fascist takeover you keep banging
on about and it's no there is no equivalence between these things
I disagree by the way you know is entitled to criticize Charlie
Kirk and his positions on the show that's absolely absolutely
fine. But when you label and smear people as fascists and that
is taking it to an entirely different level and that is where
I hope there would be some self-reflection but I'm not seeing
any on this panel tonight I'm afraid. >> No and it's interesting
you know I remember the Madison Square >> I don't think
fascists really that far off and I think probably far off but
like honestly it's um it's just totally disingenuous to say that
Republicans don't do the same kind of hyperbole. They absolutely
do. They absolutely have. They won the election based on it.
So, I don't know where it needs to stop everywhere, right? >> Square
Garden Rally just before the election. And I went to that because
I'd never been to any political rally for anyone, but Trump uh
said, "Why don't you come down?" I went down and I was really
struck by the fact that it was being branded by the left from
Hillary Clinton to MSNBC and others as a rally. They compared
it to one in the 30s at the Madison Square Garden which was indeed
a
rally and I thought then it was incredibly dangerous but also
incredibly stupid. There were many Jewish people in the audience
and was a Holocaust survivor a prominent one in the audience.
Donald Trump his son is his daughter converted to Judaism. The
idea that he is the new Adolf Hitler has
>> always been utterly preposterous. But to take your point
Constantine, >> why did JD say it then? >> I completely
did say it. >> If you are telling people all the time that
Trump is here and his followers are fascists, then it makes absolute
logical sense to a warped mind that they should be stopped and
that the only way to stop fascists and is with violence. And
actually in their heads they are doing society a favor. This
is the right thing to do. So the over demonization
constantly of Trump in particular and people that support him
I've always felt is extremely dangerous. >> Are we saying
that Donald Trump has never demonized his opponents? >> Not
at all. And and in fact I have completely agreed with you when
you say that there are many uh examples on the right of violence
amongst the far right. But I do think that there is just over
demonization from everybody and it it does lead disturbed minds
to believe they are doing the right good thing. You know, I haven't
heard what this shooter has to say. Apparently, he's not cooperating
with authorities now. He's he's got lawyered up and is now saying
nothing. But, you know, if he was to say, I believe that uh Charlie
Kirk is a fascist and that Donald Trump is a fascist and I was
doing this to save America from fascists. then you could understand
how his diseased mind is viewing this and it will be because
Lewis he has heard repeatedly on the airwaves for a decade now
that that is the case. >> Well sure but my point is this
Pers both sides in America and we're seeing it in the UK as well
increasingly treat and I don't welcome this at all increasingly
treat every single election as if it is an existential moment
i.e. If our side loses or the other side wins, then the country
as we've known it will be gone. Now yes, the left has parts of
the left have expressed that in terms of fascism or far right.
The right have its own vocabulary in its own way of describing
and we go back to again what Donald Trump said at the time when
he said if you don't fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore which is exactly I mean peers you're talking
about what ah I know Trump literally said that. Yes. I think
both sides trying to treat fight like hell is like a reason that
it's like obviously violent I think is stupid, right? I think
actually focusing on even on for January 6 focusing on the violence
is actually pretty dumb. Maybe not in this context specifically,
but in most cases focusing on the violence instead of the elector
plot is stupid. Okay. Oh man,
there's like such a clear there's literally a test for incitement
to violence.
I think you could try to get people to lower the temperature.
You could try to get people to bring that down. Maybe there needs
to be a lower tier test for people to say this is what should
get banned from platforms on the internet. I don't know. I don't
know. It's um it's I think it's to me the fight like hell stuff,
the fight any anything about like like fighting using uh like
aggressive or violent imagery is okay.
You do have to differentiate. You do have to make it clear you
don't mean anything about like actually hurting people, actually
getting violent with >> Depraved minds here or demented
minds here and they go and turn to violent. That is precisely
what we saw with January the 6th. That is what we see again and
again and again. And what I just find not only distasteful but
frankly demented is the idea that somehow we can say that this
is a problem which is unique to one side of politics. It's a
problem it's a problem which actually begats each other. It's
a problem which each side it metastasizes this problem of political
violence. Each side each time adds fuel to the fire and it gets
hot. It gets hot inside the building. So the truth is we've all
got to acknowledge acknowledge and you're talking about what
happens in the far right and so on in different parts of the
world. We're braced in London right now for what might happen
tomorrow in terms of violent protest on the streets of London
with Tommy Robinson. We saw what happened in terms of violent
protest all throughout the course of the last year. This is a
problem which happens on the left and it is a problem on the
right and it must be acknowledged in order to do anything and
something about it. >> Okay, Lewis, thank you for joining
us today. I know you got to leave us. We really appreciate it.
I'll come back to the panel for more in a moment. We're going
to be joined now by Alex Marlo, a close friend of Charlie Kirk,
Breitbart, editor and host of the Alex Marlo podcast. Alex, first
of all, uh my deep sympathies to you as a friend of >> I
like this guy. Uh it's who is it? It's
Lewis Goodall. Lewis Goodall. >> Charlie's I wasn't a friend
of his. I I knew him. I'd interviewed him a few times. Had a
lot of respect for the extraordinary empire he built for himself.
And I had a lot of respect for the fact that he would willingly,
regularly go into the heart of the people that vehemently disagree
with him and have open debate and and do so often very respectfully
and politely, but he would allow them to challenge him and he
would challenge them. And we saw him do that. This is just Charlie
glazing. This just glazing for the rest of this. Okay, we're
we're done with this. We're good with this. What else is there?
Oh, I know what I was going to do with a lot of the rest of tonight.
Um, there's the Candace Owens versus Fuentes stuff.
Candace Owens has started a fight, decided to start a fight with
Nick Fuentes tonight. Okay, you watch the vid now. Oh, sure.
I guess so.
Give me a second. Uh, give me a second. [__] Did
this go not go to my downloads? Hello. The heck? Oh, I don't
have it downloaded. Hold on. Give me a second. Reuben Ruben,
I'll pull it up right now. Give me a second. Put it stream chat.
I should make you pay more for this kind of stuff.
Ooh,
dude.
[__] Wow. >> Oh my god. Here he goes. >> The
party of peace, everybody. Did you see that? Party of acceptance
right >> We didn't call ourselves that. You did. >> So
much for tolerance.
>> I exhaled air through my nostrils pretty aggressively
there.
Just so you know. Okay. Just so you know.
Exhaled some air through my nostrils. Um, I'm going to wait to
cover this. Hold on.
Dude, I wonder if there'd be like clips from this.
I don't want to watch like the whole thing. I just watched like
straight raid argue with uh
guy for like a little bit. Charleston White's take. Dude, I saw
some people pulling up Charleston White's take. Give me a second.
Let's pull it up. See what it is. I heard it was bad. >> I
don't give a about Kirk's death. I don't give a [__]
about no white man die. I don't give a [__] about
no [__] white boy die.
>> Blind [__] Soon as a [__] hit
the stage, they gonna ask about >> Yeah. What did you think
he thought? Yeah, he's racist. He's racist. He's always been
racist.
I don't see I don't get people getting like really upset about
this for the same reason that I don't get like I I think it's
goofy for um rightwingers to go and get like upset about anyone
laughing at him, right? It's it's like why would I go look up
somebody I know is racist? Why would I see this and go, "Oh,
I really care about this guy's opinion." Yeah, this guy's like
a total loser.
Hey, watch it back to back. >> Yeah, they want it back
to back. I took a break. Confused. That's bad to [__]
>> They got curled by about a white boy being killed by
another white boy. I don't give a [__] about no white
boy. Give a [__] about [__] [__]
about no
>> And he wearing a cross right now. I thought this guy
was like Christian or something. Like is he wearing a cross?
>> Hey, man. I don't give a [__] about no white
boy getting killed.
kill [__] We go zero to 100, [__] Real.
He has two kids. [__] his kids. Give a [__]
about that white boy kid. They probably anyway. Give a [__]
about that white boy kid. >> Okay, that's a little funny.
>> [__] them kids. >> That's a little
funny.
>> They're probably autistic anyway. Okay, that's a little
funny. >> Baby white boy. Any white baby [__]
about no white boy. White on white crime. I don't give a [__]
about white on white crime. H white people don't care about black
on black. [__] that white boy in this deal. >> Okay,
I do think way more than this if I was going to watch something
for the rest of the show. Okay, >> ladies and gentlemen,
welcome. >> I'm thinking about watching the Tim Dylan podcast.
If I remember correctly,
I think him and Max, this Max Blumenthal from uh what is it?
Not Gayscale. Uh what is it? Oh, I can't remember this guy's
publication that he's a part of. The Gray Zone. The Gray Zone.
Yeah, I think they just talk about Israel Charlie Kirk for a
while.
So, you know what? I kind of I kind of want to watch this. I
kind of want to watch it. >> He's sitting there. He's engaging
in conversations with people. He was under. I didn't know Charlie.
I never met him. I knew people that knew him well. Everybody
um liked him. Oh god. Why? Tim Dylan is a techone level. Techone
or sorry, Tim Dylan could be funny. Never heard of him, you know,
insulting anybody. So, I don't know if I call him techone level,
but uh I just want to watch some conspiracy people
>> Both people I know on the Democratic side liked him
and people on the Republican side obviously liked him. But
>> I might not even have to go into this. Hold on. You
know what? I could I could maybe pull it back. We'll see. We'll
see if we want to watch a little more after this.
Here's the clip. The clip that I >> Does the president
of the United States >> Oh, right. This is about Trump.
>> Fear for his life. >> Yes. Yes. I mean, obviously
he fears for his life. And I was told that he feared for his
life before the two assassination attempts. One coming within
a millimeter of striking his head. I mean, let's not forget about
>> But I mean, just to clarify, he doesn't fear for his
life because of Ireland. I I mean, I've been told, yes, that
Israel is a major source of concern for Wait, >> why why
do he say it like that? Why do you say literally Israel? >> Trump.
I mean, think about it. Your source of concern for Yes. That
Israel is a major source of concern for Trump. I mean, think
about it.
If he suspended arms,
>> if he suspended arms to a country that carries out assassinations
all across the globe, that specializes in assassinations, that
has an entire wing of its intelligence services, that conducts
assassinations, including with household goods like pagers.
uh would you not be scared? So yes, Trump is scared. And what
I learned
uh from this source who is a Trump insider, someone who talks
to the who has, you know, who talks to people in the Oval Office,
people close to Trump. >> Sorry, it's getting like tweets
sent occasionally. Why did Veto tweet this?
Did the guy Did the guy kill anyone? No. Sorry. I've obtained
a photo, an additional photo of Lance Twigs, the transitioning
roommate and lover of Charlie Kirk's assassin, Tyler Robinson.
He says, "Did the guy kill anyone?" No. In fact, he turned in
her murderous roommate to the cops. Does he mean she turned in?
If he is trans,
if he Vito's really mixing up the pronouns here. What the If
he is trans, that means a trans person is the hero of this situation.
No, he did. They didn't turn him in. The guy turned himself in.
Dude, there's like no good information anywhere on the internet.
Like, everybody is wrong on everything they see and and read
and and learn. Like, none of these people know what the actual
truth is anymore.
Dad turned him in. No, no, no. Dad Dad and pastor convinced him
to turn himself in. He surrendered himself.
No, they convinced him to go and surrender himself to the cops.
Yeah. Yeah. Anyway, >> is that during >> splitting
hairs? No. Yeah, it doesn't really matter to me. What's not splitting
hairs is the person, the roommate didn't have anything to do
with >> One of Netanyahu's many visits to the the you know,
so who talks to people in the Oval Office, people close to Trump,
>> is that
during one of Netanyahu's many visits to the US this year, uh
some figures in his retinue, Israeli agents placed electronic
devices on emergency
>> Uh Will, I did not see this link. >> Secret Service
vehicles. Secret Service found them and they reported this to
the White House. You know, these would be emergency response
vehicles
uh that would respond to an incident potentially involving the
president. >> Oh, the that's odd. Why Why does Israel keep
doing that weird? Why do they do weird like that? Huh?
Watch the full interview. I think I will watch the full interview.
It's Max. Come on. I don't know. I'll watch a little bit of the
leadup, too. Give me a second. That was one of the most disturbing
things I had ever seen in my >> Um, uh, the man is a a
husband, a father, even if he wasn't, he's a human being. He's
sitting there, he's engaging in conversations with people, and
he was brutally murdered in front of his wife and children. Um,
I'm not a sanctimonious guy. I dressed up as a dead healthcare
CEO on Netflix. I'm not someone who is out there uh being a purveyor
of good taste, but I I just don't understand how after witnessing
that murder, you could be gleefully celebrating this attack.
I think you're >> okay. Hold on. >> He was walking.
>> Not to get like totally totally totally uh what do you
call it? ADHD here. Okay. But Charlie Cart killer Tyler Robinson
spotted kissing trans partner 2 weeks before assassination. >> Yeah,
he was walking with him. >> Were they holding hands? >> Uh
yeah, they were.
So yeah, they I mean they drove off in his car, the the Dodge
>> Um the time you saw them or this week? >> Um it
was about the time >> I wouldn't trust the sun. Do you
think their son is lying about who these people are? >> Saw
them. >> Was one of their neighbors? >> I would say
about two weeks ago. >> And do they So they look like they
were a couple.
>> And he was dressed all in black. >> Yeah, definitely.
>> Mhm. And you thought he was weird? >> Yeah, I
I definitely Yeah. >> What was weird about him? >> Um,
just the way he walked and just the way I've seen him. I've never
seen really anybody dressed all in black with a mask on and I
thought that was just quite weird. For those who have never seen
the roommate, despite